I bet it's me it is of the utmost  importance to give the people in your  life proper greetings for example this  is my friend  cinnamon bun you Cooper when I say bun I  do this but when I see cookie my best  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  [Music]  hello  it is I the wisest of all cupcakes I'm  about to tell you something something  very important there's one thing that  you have to do for yourself right now  give us even though it really sucks  I feel sadder even not when you can eat  with me  you just give us then you'll surely be  in luck just give spring is here  remember to take the time to stop and  smell the flowers good advice cupcake  sometimes the best thing you can do for  yourself it's nothing at all  I'm a burrito now  [Music]